all right so i wrote this song this is
the first weekend i'm doing it without
my notebook so i hope i remember it
i'm not a good guitar player i wrote
this um
uh song around valentine's day because
my wife is just so good at buying
[ __ ] gifts
but i always tell her you think too hard
about it gifts for guys super easy
you don't have to think so hard father's
day
valentine's day birthday doesn't matter
and so this song is she's actually right
here tonight so
this song you want to bring her out
you're always so thoughtful and
gifts on my special day
asking friends and family about things
that make
me feel great
but let me try to help you
[Music]
let me ease your mind
i just want a [ __ ] and a sandwich
[Music]
let me save you some time i want a
[ __ ]
and a sandwich i don't need another
[ __ ] tie and i haven't worn cologne
since the 8th grade
you and your sister use the couple's
massage
i want a [ __ ] and a sandwich
[Music]
at the same time
at the same time
at the same time tiny tiny tiny tiny
tiny tiny time
[Music]
i like turkey on wheat
i like ham on ride
to make this day complete well there's
one more thing that i'd like to try
now i know when guys say try
women always think that we're talking
about anal
[Music]
and that's true
[Music]
but not this time
i just like a [ __ ] and a sandwich
while i'm watching tv
turn on espn and little march madness
watching men dribble balls up and down
[Music]
now i know on your special day i'll give
you
anything that you need
[Music]
trips jewelry or clothing i'd bring the
moon
down to its knees
you don't have to tell me i know what
you
really want
[Music]
you want me naked you're washing dishes
and a ryan gosling mass
throwing votes in the rain
telling all of your friends
quotes from the notebook over again
i wrote her every single day
[Music]
what end of what guns and roses song is
that patience right
[Music]
let's see if we get the voice tonight
for this
[Music]
sandwich
[Music]
[Applause]
while i watch tv man i promise not to
get any crumbs on your head
i just wanna blow job while i watch some
tv
that'll feel so fine to me in a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
who is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you